Paolantonio ESPN national correspondent
also hosting the NFL matchup show with a
Greg Cosell Matt Bowen it airs Saturday
at 7:00 a.m. Eastern on espn2 and again
on Sunday mornings at 6:00 a.m. Eastern
and you can find it on the ESPN app Sal
Powell joins us from the NFL film studio
Sal good morning what's the coolest
thing at the NFL Films studio Steve
Sabol and the late Steve Sabol who was a
mentor of mine president NFL Films the
guy who really put NFL Films on the map
his office here is still intact how he
left it you know he passed away of brain
damage many years ago but they keep it
as sort of a museum and a memoriam to
this guy and it outside of his office is
one of the coolest rooms in football
it's all the electric football games
going back to like the 1920's and 1930's
a raid along a wall and you can just go
into the room and sometimes I just go
into that room and I sit in that chair
and I imagine that the football games
come to life like in a Jumanji movie you
know and the players could have chased
me down the hallway I said it's one of
the coolest places on earth it really is
I was always wondering this that I think
sax became an official stat in what 1982
but you have this archival footage why
hasn't the NFL gone back and I know it's
a lot of work but I mean sacks are so
important or interceptions or you know I
don't know any other stat that you'd
want to have them go back to you know
document but I would think sacks would
be one that I'd love to know how many
sacks Deacon Jones really had in his
career yeah I'd like to know how many
sacks
Andy robust Elliott where Jim cat
cabbage number Sam Hoffman yeah I mean
you know let's go back in the day and
find out how many you know when when
Tom Landry invented the 4-3 defense of
the New York Giants in the 50s one of
the things that they did in that 4-3
defense was attacked the quarterback in
a way that they'd never done before I'd
like to know what kind of sack
percentage the New York Giants defense
had against the Cleveland Browns in the
50s that'd be fun all right the game
this weekend with the Eagles and the
Cowboys the importance of this game for
both teams is what well the importance
for the Cowboys is real simple you got
to stop the bleeding you're on a
three-game losing streak you're at home
you're on Sunday Night Football
you're on prime-time television you're
against your division rival it's the
biggest game of the year here in
Philadelphia
it's Cowboys week Eagles are coming to
town you got to stop the bleeding and if
you're Jason Garrett and you're not sure
of the health of your number-one weapon
and offense Amari Cooper you got to go
back to basics you got to go back to
Ezekiel Elliott you got to feed him the
football you got to make them earn the
money you got to keep your offense on
the field and on schedule run the
football with zico Elliott throw it to
them create matchups that are favorable
to you on the Eagles linebackers which
is pretty easy to do some teams have
already shown the ability to do that and
I think that's the key from just a
football standpoint you got to generate
some confidence and production on
offense using the running game and keep
Carson Wentz off the field as for the
Eagles I think it's real simple what has
been their biggest problem they've given
up 13 touchdown passes and that's that's
you know the Patriots have only given up
one Dan the Eagles have 13 I mean it the
only teams that are worse or Arizona
Miami Washington Atlanta teams like that
that's not you don't want to be in that
company so they have to keep stuff in
front of them and again without Cooper
on the field or without a healthy Cooper
that should be easier now Stefon Dix is
not going to be on the field
not going to be on the field that that
should be a lot easier when you run your
offense primarily in the passing game
through the tight end as it happened for
both these teams the offense becomes
very pedestrian Zach Ertz who is one of
eight tight ends that leads his team in
receptions but he's 15th in yards after
the catch
among tight ends that's pedestrian same
thing with Witten witnessed 22nd in the
league in yards after the catch if you
run it through your tight end in the
passing game it's hard to have those big
chunks of yards and explosive plays and
that means your offense has to be super
super efficient because you can't make
mistakes what is the confidence level do
you think of Carson Wentz his teammates
in him very very high I'm around that
team a lot and I've been around Carson
Wentz since the day he was drafted he's
thought of extremely highly Carson Wentz
is the consummate teammate he's a super
hard worker you know all that talk last
year about him being selfish is a bunch
of baloney yeah it really is
you know you know and you talk to
players they say you know his truck is
the first one in the parking lot each
and every day is he different from Nick
Foles
of course they're different people you
know Carson once wants to know exactly
how everything works all the time
Nick Foles you hand him the play but the
game plan and say run this and he's like
ok gotcha the Carson Wentz wants input
and so I think there's some of that
personality difference that was
interpreted improperly in my view I
think he's really well regarded and
let's face it his numbers are down
because the Eagles lead the NFL in drop
Stan we're talking to Sal Paolantonio
ESPN NFL reporter I even had dramatic
pause there before I reintroduce you
know just like I was letting that
statement breathe just a little bit so
just let you know that was NFL Films
style can you see the Chiefs doing you
know Andy Reid well could you see Andy
Reid going
outside the organization to bring in a
quarterback depending on the extent of
the injury with mahomes definitely not
you know Andy Reid is a guy who prepares
contingency plans for players that go
down within within his group and I'm not
sure even who would be out there I think
for the Chiefs you know now they can't
rely on the pyrotechnics every week you
know the no-look passes and all that
they got to go back to basic football
you know foot you got to run it when
they tell when they think you're going
to pass it and you got to pass it when
they think you're going to run it and
you can you can be successful and Steve
Spagnola has got to hold up his end of
the bargain
right you can see what's happening in
the rest of the NFL Bill Belichick
defense has given up a ridiculous eight
points a game they're on a historic run
right now why because he's playing
man-to-man lights-out man-to-man defense
you know I'm not a see my mother that's
a pad I'm not a guy in the in the film
room 70 hours a week but when you look
at them they're they're lining up and
saying all right go ahead and try to
beat us
and everybody's imitating that and that
Patricia former you know Belichick
acolyte imitating that in Detroit Romeo
Crennel is doing it in Houston you see
them doing it in Indianapolis you see
them trying to do it here in
Philadelphia but they don't have the
horses why our teams going man-to-man
Dan because the ball is coming out of
the quarterbacks hands at an alarmingly
fast rate at historically fast rate you
have 19 quarterbacks now in the NFL snap
to release under 2.5 seconds the balls
coming out of the quarterbacks hands so
quickly that if you're not up on the
line of scrimmage disrupting the routes
or the wide receivers inside ends and
backs you're going to lose you're gonna
lose and Belichick has perfected it and
I think that's what the Chiefs need to
do they've got to look at
they're doing defensively man up and
play tougher defense at the line of
scrimmage I'll leave you with this the
second-best team in the AFC right now is
Wow yeah because you know you just lost
the MVP right in Kansas City the
reigning MVP so it would have been easy
this morning to say the Chiefs and
Patrick mahomes and Andy Reed but you
can't say that right now so I'm gonna
say the Baltimore Ravens okay even
though they lost a ridiculous game at
home to Cleveland and I was there and I
covered it I couldn't believe it
happened the Ravens have something that
you can take on the road in October
November and December
that is they can run the football and
they can run it in a way that's scary
right when you have to dedicate a hat on
defense to Lamar Jackson evacuating the
pocket and getting on the run you got to
account for him as a runner that changes
the equation it opens up everything for
everybody and that's why you're seeing a
Mark Ingram have a second act in
Baltimore and why you see the line what
it is you know it's it's a post game you
it's tough to go up into Seattle and be
a hot Seahawks team right now where
Russell Wilson is on everybody's MVP
conversation list but I think the Ravens
are right now the second best team in
the AFC good to visit with you Sal
thanks for joining us have a good
weekend thanks Dan let's sell
Paolantonio ESPN national correspondent
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]